and if you're heading down to Comicon
this week Conan O'Brien is bringing his
talk-show back to the Spreckels theater
for the Thoreau Haro should be a great
week of show so hey how about some
driving music yeah we have to listen to
this song it's pretty annoying oh you
don't like this song oh you can just
skip to the next track great it's all
the same songs they're all the same flaw
I love this song all right well okay I
can't really do it I'm sorry uh yeah you
can cuz it's my truck it's my tunes oh
no I really I don't want to listen to
that song I'm sorry we're gonna listen
to that song
I'm your guests you should have some
considerations yeah I'm considering
kicking your ass out of this
no you won't what I like that's it get
out
san Diego's like 70 miles away well if
you start walking now you should be
there in time for the first show let me
out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I should be in San Diego by now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is it can we eat it
it's skin is so translucent like a sea
jelly
I shall poke it let us all poke
where am i this is the mascara but
hidden island of the Amazons and we will
care for you until you're ready to
return to the ocean sea jelly so we're
definitely not eating it I am NOT a sea
jelly I'm a man yes yes I'm a guy who
really has a concussion we have these
ancient drawings of what a man is
supposed to look like you know that's
from a long time ago men don't look like
that anymore you're not this that guy is
overdoing it when they don't find that
attractive I know I don't look like
right now it's closed no you have the
voice of a child will it change as you
grow into manhood my voice already
changed this is a man's voice it's
really like like Alan Alda stop no don't
say it like that
no it's one way to find out what the sea
jelly speaks the truth tell us what are
you the truth is I am a man I also don't
tip when I get takeout food I figure
they didn't wait on me I'm getting the
food so what should I tip I've never
been to my children's school I didn't
vote in the last election
I just thought Hillary
now tell us male what purpose could you
possibly serve on this group of islands
archipelago what a group of islands
technically that's Pogan archipelago
male no no we don't call it males
planing we call it mansplaining that's
what a man me it's combined they think
you're forgetting as a man I'm endowed
with certain equipment you better step
back all right
[Applause]
[Music]
where is it it's out so watch it that's
it no that's not it
look out it's there if you have to say
that it's not there wow this is my ball
penis come on let me stay I can right
there
[Music]
Luke who came crawling back well say the
land it's only two hours to San Diego
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you